move on to some of the other ones and uh  i know there's a lot of respect for a  lot of players but  do you do you ex did you expect this to  happen  and i'm just going to put that on the  board harry this is mainly for the  uh i mean the point is it's for  entertainment purpose  so there is a lot of uh section who  likes that  and uh hikaru is uh  i mean he's doing it for i mean we also  saw magnus carlsen doing it  along with hikaru but uh personally  i would not do that and uh it's not  because of respect or something i just  think that uh  it's bad position  and you must punish it i love this  attitude you got harry it's just all  about the position and  uh you know i i did say earlier that  does remind me of bobby fischer because  bobby fischer was asked a couple of  times in interviews he was asked  what's your style of play and his  response was i just play the best moves